new Ghostbusters but I'm not gifted this
one caught me off guard I had no idea
this was coming out I think I heard
about it but I didn't expect a trailer
today anyhow so yeah we have a trailer
our first trailer - Ghostbusters
afterlife which is essentially
Ghostbusters 3 so yeah Finn wolfhard
plays Egon Spengler grandson it does
make that from stranger things it makes
it a bit funnier and they're out in the
middle of nowhere in this creepy farm
and there's a seismic activity and you
know it's gonna be ghost activity and so
these kids basically become ghostbusters
which there's a couple things about that
that I like first of all it's not just a
rehash of Ghostbusters it's not like all
right now you're the new Ghostbusters
but it's the same basic plot as
Ghostbusters it just feels like a
retread in which case people will be
like oh it's like the old one but not as
good as the old one it's easier to
compare the two this looks like a new
thing it looks like it's it's a kid
adventure it's like Goonies with
ghostbusters so now they're free of that
it's not really like ghostbusters it's
like a continuing chapter in the
Ghostbusters universe one could
logically call it ghostbusters 3 so
knowing that that's the thing I like in
the original Ghostbusters that I'm not
gonna get in ghostbusters afterlife I
like the fact these guys are busting
ghosts not in the middle of nowhere but
now downtown Manhattan this definitely
is like alright yeah it was we're in the
middle of Roanoke where we are they're
in the middle of this farm it's like
Annabelle but with ghostbusters so this
actually could have some neat play on
that genre you know the genre of haunted
houses in the middle of nowhere on farms
and jason reitman wrote and directed
this movie jason reitman is the son of
Ivan Reitman I have been writing as the
director of ghostbusters and that
doesn't automatically make for success
just because you share a bloodline
doesn't mean you're gonna do it well and
jason reitman 'he's done great work in
his filmography absolutely I'm just
saying there's no guarantee but seeing
this trailer you do feel like there is a
sense of respect and love for the legacy
of ghostbusters I am confused as to how
no one knew what happened in Manhattan I
get it it's free internet free social
media but there's a lot of stuff
pre-internet priests social media that
finds its way on to social media
I'm sure the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
would have found his way on YouTube by
now same with the Statue of Liberty
walking through New York you know that's
there are questions questions that I
don't think they're gonna answer I'm not
counting on them answering just things I
have in my head then we go okay whatever
just watch the movie I'm gonna say it
and I mean this in a good way I mean
this has a compliment cuz this phrase is
either used as an insult or a compliment
I mean it is
the movie by this trailer kind of looks
like a fan fell again I mean it in a
good way because we've seen those fan
films you've seen them you know like
those fan films that you can tell are
made by a fan with passion it doesn't
feel like studio it feels like
a fan who loves the property who wants
to see a great take on that property you
walk away going yeah they do it better
than the studio's do that's what this
trailer looks like it looks like just a
fan who wanted to see the continuation
of ghostbusters and then here we are
here's a new chapter thirty years later
I feel like that's probably actually
pretty close to how Jason Reitman
streeting not a stretch to say he's
probably a fan of his dad's work and
will respect the legacy I feel bad for
all the kids in this movie you know cuz
I'm sure they were just like oh sweet I
want to be in a Ghostbusters movie and I
am very sure they're gonna be stuck in
some sort of weird Twitter culture war
somehow while Twitter burns to the
ground over it there's gonna be like
you've already seen a couple people
pissed off about it because I guess it's
sexist to do this after the 2016 coast
Busters that I just don't think it's
sexist to go a different direction when
you're 2016 reboot failed to impress
going where the money is and staying
away from where the money is not and
leaving something when you find out it's
not gonna make you money it just sounds
like a reasonable business decision
making anyhow that's my rant on it keep
the kids out of it I'm sorry so yeah
this trailer really impressed me like
when I found out hey I'm about to watch
a new trailer to a new Ghostbusters
movie it's like you kind of think you
know where it's gonna go and didn't
really go that direction it's a
different thing for Ghostbusters that
they're doing Goonies meets ghostbusters
could be pretty cool time will tell I
saw the first trailer - Ghostbusters
afterlife is actually a pretty sweet
title - it just encompasses the whole
concept anyhow did you see it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you